So the other thing that we don't know is what price we paid for for accelerated
Iq from from a broader perspective.
You know,
because I know that there is some evidence,
and you can tell me what you think about this because I know that there's
reasonable evidence that the average Iq of the Ashkenazi Jewish population is
about 15 points higher than the standard population,
which is kind of makes it a thought experiment.
It's an experiment,
real life experiment.
It's equivalent to the one that you laid out.
But Aszkenazy Jews also tend to suffer from a host of neurological diseases that
seem to be associated with increased neural plasticity.
And so to me it's often,
it's often hard to gain on one front without losing on another,
you know,
I mean that's the evolutionary can hundred obviously,
but we call that the social justice theory,
that one thing you have to be bad on everything else to kind of balance it out.
All these speaking,
you do pay a price for your,
for your exceptionalism.
You know that that's true.
Because you know,
the,
the Julian Stanley's studies of the mathematic reaper,
cautious kids,
essentially,
we found not only were they smart,
but they were more mature than their age peers.
Better looking,
they were color.
They were physically more fit.
I mean,
it was kind of the antisocial.
No,
that's true.
Well,
I mean,
it's just,
it,
that also might be true because one of the things that,
that,
that can interfere with Iq is poor health and poor nutritional quality and all
of that.
I mean,
it doesn't look like it's that easy to increase Iq,
but it looks like it's pretty easy to decrease it.